Speaker 1: This is just an unbelievable story.
After months and months of wrangling, trying
to avoid providing call records to the House
Committee investigating the Jan. six Trump
riots.
The Trump White House, the former White House,
finally provided the call records to the January
6th Committee.
Great.
Right?
I mean, what delightful?
They've got the information they need.
No, the January six call logs provided by
Trump to the committee.
Have a seven hour gap on January 6th, the
key hours during which it is crucial and critical
to understand who was Trump speaking to.
Now there's a second layer to this, which
is they may have had phone calls that they
never put in the log.
So there's kind of two layers of accountability.
The first is give us the logs so we can see
who you spoke to.
That assumes the logs are accurate.
And I would not assume that with this former
administration.
But the next part of it is, of course, well,
do the calls even reflect what what they should
reflect?
Washington Post report Very good report by
Bob Woodward and Robert Costa.
January six White House logs given to the
House show a seven hour gap.
Wow.
The House Select Committee is now investigating
whether it has the full record and whether
Trump communicated that day through back channels,
phones of aides or personal disposable phones.
Now Trump is claiming he doesn't know what
a burner phone is.
I don't believe that for a second.
We're going to get to that in a moment.
Read the whole article we're linking to it.
Internal White House records from the day
of the attack that were turned over to the
House Select Committee show a gap in Trump's
phone logs of seven hours and 37 minutes,
including what a surprise.
The period when the building was being violently
assaulted, according to documents obtained
by The Washington Post and CBS News.
The lack of an official White House notation
of any calls placed to or by Trump for 457
minutes look at the time here from 11:17 a.m.
to 6:54 pm trying to think what was going
on during that time.
Oh, right.
That was exactly when the Capitol was taken
over by violent insurrectionists attempting
to overturn the results of the election.
Well, during that time, we don't have the
logs.
That means the committee has no record of
his phone conversations as his supporters
descended on the Capitol, battled overwhelmed
police and forcibly entered the building,
prompting lawmakers and VP Mike Pence to flee
for safety.
The 11 pages of records, which consist of
the president's official daily diary and the
White House switchboard call logs, were turned
over by the National Archives earlier this
year.
The records show Trump was active on the phone
for part of the day, documenting conversations
with at least eight people in the morning
and 11 in the evening.
But there is this seven hour gap that stands
in stark contrast to the extensive public
reporting about phone calls he had with allies
during the attack.
We know he spoke to Mike Lee.
He spoke to Tommy Tuberville.
He spoke to Kevin McCarthy and many others.
So in essence, they didn't really turn over
the records in that we don't actually have
the records or the White House doesn't during
those key moments.
Now I want to talk about this burner thing.
This is now from a CBS News article.
Remember that this was a kind of joint report
from Washington Post and CBS.
The House panel is now investigating whether
Trump communicated through back channels,
meaning he could have used other people's
phones or personal disposable phones known
as burner phones.
Look at this.
In a statement Monday night, Trump said, I
have no idea what a burner phone is.
To the best of my knowledge, I have never
even heard the term.
Does anybody believe that, does anybody believe
that Donald Trump doesn't know what a burner
phone is?
I know he's not the brightest, but there is
no doubt that he knows what a burner phone
is, the stuff that Trump has been up to for
so long now.
Is it possible he doesn't know it by that
name?
He knows it as a disposable phone.
I don't know, guys, maybe, maybe, but this
is not believable.
And when we talk about.
Remember when we spoke about the Ukraine fiasco
that led to the second impeachment?
Remember when we spoke about the entire Russia
probe, quite frankly, as I've said before,
if from the beginning of the suspicions about
Russia, the Mueller investigation, the entire
thing.
Much of what took place was self-inflicted
harm done by Trump.
If Trump hadn't gone public and tweeted all
sorts of things that attracted more attention
to the story, if Trump hadn't gone overboard
in his denials and then it came out, actually,
they met with all of these Russian individuals
and all these different things.
The investigation would never have become
what it was.
And similarly, when it comes to January six,
it is increasingly plausible that had Trump
just cooperated and not called attention to
the fact that he's obviously trying to cover
up the full scope of what he did and what
he said and who he spoke to that day.
This also likely would not be as big as it
is because, to be perfectly frank, my opinion
is whatever is in those missing seven and
a half hours, it's probably not good.
But if you don't have the contents of those
calls, you have a circumstantial case at best,
most likely.
And again, the fact that there is a seven
and a half hour gap in the records at exactly
the key time that's being investigated is
just putting more of a focus on that time
and suggesting that Donald Trump knows that
he did something wrong.
So I'm not suggesting Trump is innocent.
But what I am suggesting is that the cover
up after the fact, the actions are putting
more of a spotlight when you don't give seven
and a half hours of logs.
You're saying these are the seven and a half
hours that you want to focus on.
Now, unfortunately, and I know we continue
to have this discussion, you and I in the
audience.
It's not looking to me like there are going
to be any consequences here.
Number one, there seems to be no willingness
on the part of any prosecutor to actually
look at criminal charges for any of what's
taking place.
And no, to listen.
Trump is pretty Teflon.
It's just the reality, and he's thinking about
running again in 2024.
There's the possibility that even running
again may be part of keeping himself out of
trouble, trouble by being back in power.
And I remain pessimistic about accountability
here, but in the last 24 hours, just incredible
stories and a seven and a half hour gap in
the phone records.
If you believe that we are finally getting
to where it's overwhelming.
There are going to be consequences.
Let me know you can find me on Twitter at
David Pakman and let me know what you think
is coming.
The David Pakman Show is primarily made possible
by viewers and listeners like you who sign
up on our website for the membership program,
we do an extra show every day for our members
and I would love for you to sign up.
You know, we very often kind of don't even
think about the fact that we contribute a
few bucks a month to all sorts of channels
whose politics we may not agree with.
If you have a cable TV subscription, you are
contributing a few bucks a month to some channels.
I guarantee you you don't like, and we should
think about contributing a couple of bucks
to programs we actually do like and want to
support.
And you can do that by signing up at Join
Packman dot com and you can use the coupon
code Wow!
Twenty two to get a discount.